in case you didn't know it was spelt out
across the capital then they rang out
the news across the country
Westminster's town crier let everyone
know outside the Lindo wing the future
King had been born
this is a moment of history and it's a
wonderful wonderful moment for the whole
nation
very exciting very very exciting I was
hoping for a boy while news Kate had
given birth to a baby boy emerged first
on email via Kensington Palace the
theater soon followed the notice of
birth was carried out of the Lindo wing
by the Duke and Duchess's press
secretary and it began its journey to
Buckingham Palace William and Kate it
said were parents to a baby boy
delivered at 4:24 in the afternoon
weighing 8 pounds and 6 ounces as the
bulletin was placed on the very easily
used to announce William's birth it
emerged the Duke was present throughout
the Queen who earlier returned to
Buckingham Palace from Windsor said she
and the Duke of Edinburgh were delighted
with the news grandfather for the first
time Prince Charles in York alongside
the Duchess of Cornwall was overjoyed
saying it was a special moment for
William and Catherine and he couldn't
wait to see the baby in the near future
and from Downing Street the Prime
Minister sent his best wishes to the new
parents it's wonderful news from Sir
Mary's Paddington and I'm sure that
right across the country and indeed
right across the Commonwealth people
will be celebrating and wishing the
royal couple
it is an important moment in the life of
our nation but I suppose above all it's
a wonderful moment for a warm and loving
couple we've got a brand-new baby boy as
well wishes continued to be magnetized
to Buckingham Palace and of course said
Mary's Hospital the new heirs name was
still unknown
kate begins to get used to motherhood
while hundreds outside waited patiently
for the first comments from a proud
father Paul Harrison Sky News Paddington